in fact this is a really important point
the browser can't really tell that it's
definitively online it can't tell that
it's definitively offline either unless
it really has no connection to another
device at all in fact there's an
attribute navigator online that
supposedly tells you whether you're
online or not there's also a pair of
events that fire on the body of the
document when you go online or offline
however I don't recommend relying on
these they really just tell you if
there's a network connection or not they
don't tell you if that network
connection is actually connected to
anything for example my computer at home
is occasionally fooled because my cable
modem will go out but my computer is
still connected to the router sometimes
computers or applications will use pings
to various servers to tell them if
there's a connection to the internet but
fundamentally as a developer the only
offline status that matters to you is
can you get to your own servers and of
course in the cellular radio case it can
be even more complex we've all had the
experience of having one bar signal and
trying to use the network in fact this
is a critical point to offline use and
why we say you need to build offline
first you might think the way to support
offline is to use the network first and
then if it fails you can rely on the
cash but that doesn't really work in the
real world precisely because it can take
a long time to determine if you don't
really have an internet connection if
you only offer cash data once a network
request has definitively failed you
leave users waiting while their device
desperately tries but fails to actually
transfer data over the network this is
what we mean by offline first not that
you should code offline first but to
underscore that your app has to be able
to use cache data first and then update
the cache contents when it's online but
continue to use old data from the cash
when it's offline